gib niemals auf höhere niemals auf zu
kämpfen
der kampf um den es geht ist der kampf
ums wählen dürfen bis 1928 durch den
frauen in großbritannien nicht wählen
geändert hat er sich das weil
aktivistinnen neunzehnten jahrhundert
dafür kämpfen sie nannten sich so von
betten und hatten die hoffnung auf
friedliche proteste aufgegeben doch es
geht will sie das recht so zu sehen wie
mitten in einem aufruf frauen verprügeln
geld und nichts
das gesetz bedeutet mir nicht sicher
aber der gesetzgebung keine steckdose
oder aufschrieb gesetzt die nerven
fenster wir brennen dinge nieder
der krieg ist die einzige sprache die
männer verstehen können ihr habt uns
geprügelt und betrogen und uns bleibt
nichts anderes übrig dann bleibt uns
nichts übrig als sich auf zu halten und
das ist die kernbotschaft des films nur
durch das größte selbst opfer konnte die
gleichberechtigung erreicht werden und
finanzen sie nicht mehr nehmen
wir werden sie aber die rabiaten
säuberungen unter den suffragetten
werden im film allerdings ausgeblendet
doch das tut der bedeutung dieses films
kein abbruch
es war überfällig an diesem teil der
geschichte zu erinnern
geschickt erzählt der film von den neuen
repressions instrumenten die vor 100
jahren eingesetzt wurden
überwachungskameras zum beispiel oder
politiker die sich in ausschüsse
flüchten
statt versprochene reformen umzusetzen
das derzeit keinen anlass vorliegt das
britische wahlrecht neu und anders zu
formulieren
es gibt also kein wahlrecht was würde
das wahlrecht für sie bedeuten diese
spots wenn die männer zusammensitzen
denken sie sich nur unangenehme dinge
für frauen aus sowie die regisseurin
sherry jones den kampf zeigt ist er ganz
modern ist dabei im besten sinne ein
lehr- und rührstück zu klein
unterschätzen sie nicht die kraft die
wir frauen haben um unser schicksal
selbst in die hand zu nehmen
es bleibt uns nichts anderes
wieder setzen wir uns der regierung
keine gesetze brechen
wir wollen gesetze machen